[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france24 mi nombre es Álvaro Cordero la
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en Brasil vislumbraron un
país dividido entre dos candidatos
frontalmente Opuestos Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva y Yair bolsonaro dos políticos
que defienden modelos muy diferentes y
que tienen experiencia al frente de la
nación brasileña es por ello que en
France 24 repasamos como fueron sus
gobiernos
la llegada al poder del euro da Silva se
produjo en 2003 este trabajador del
metal y sindicalista de origen es
humildes gozaba de una gran fama y
respeto entre la clase Obrera brasileña
y tras tres elecciones fallidas pudo
llegar a la presidencia de su país con
un discurso progresista que se basaba en
sacar de la pobreza a millones de
familias
la verdad es que estamos muy cerca del
mayor acontecimiento histórico de este
país que es elegir a un hombre que salió
de la fábrica para ser nombrado
presidente de la República del país más
importante de latinoamérica tu país del
país más importante de Sudamérica
desde el inicio de su mandato se
desarrollaron varios programas para
combatir el hambre la desigualdad y
ayudar en la búsqueda de hogares para
los más pobres sin embargo su programa
estrella fue bolsa familia una ayuda
directa de 170 reales brasileños
mensuales unos 30 dólares que pretendía
cubrir los gastos más esenciales de las
familias más pobres su aplicación fue un
éxito Ya que según el banco
interamericano de desarrollo casi el 25%
de la población se benefició de esta
ayuda y esta apenas costó un 0,5% del
pib brasileño
su lucha contra la pobreza también vino
acompañada de un crecimiento económico
espectacular sus políticas crearon una
nueva clase media capaz de asumir un
mayor consumo que benefició al mercado y
Brasil se convirtió en un referente
dentro del comercio internacional
gracias a las exportaciones de materias
primas en un momento en el que estaban
muy cotizadas en el exterior
convirtiendo a Lula en un símbolo de la
izquierda latinoamericana y de los
países con economías en desarrollo
puntos que hicieron que Lula tuviera
gran popularidad al final de su último
mandato
Pero durante el gobierno de su sucesora
Dilma roussef su situación comenzó a
cambiar cuando varias investigaciones
por corrupción lo rodearon a él y agente
de su partido el ex presidente fue
acusado de lavado de dinero y
financiación ilegal indirecta en el
marco de la operación lavayato una de
las mayores tramas de corrupción en la
historia que involucró a miles de
funciona y cientos de empresas esta
cuestión hizo que su reputación
desapareciera y lo llevó a prisión por
más de 20 meses impidiendo que se
pudiera presentar a las elecciones de
2018 sin embargo el expresidente fue
liberado a finales de 2019 después de
que se descubriera que el juez Sergio
Moro había violado sus derechos y
cometido prevaricación al haberlo
mandado a prisión de forma preventiva
Las numerosas investigaciones que Lula
tenía en su contra Fueron anuladas por
un defecto de forma o resultaron en
absoluciones algo que le permitió volver
a la vida política para presentarse a
las elecciones presidenciales de 2022
unas elecciones en las que ha tenido que
enfrentarse a Jair bolsonaro un político
de extrema derecha cuya figura empezó a
destacar Precisamente en medio del
contexto de descrédito contra el partido
de los trabajadores por la corrupción
una situación que se sumó a la crisis
política durante el gobierno de Dilma
Rousseff y terminó con su destitución en
2016 por medio de un impeachment así
voto bolsonaro contra la expresidenta
por un Brasil encima de todo y por Dios
encima de todos Mi voto es sí
bolsonaro consiguió vencer en los
comicios de 2018 con un discurso en que
se priorizó la lucha contra la
corrupción y la promesa de unas
políticas ultraliberales que calmaran el
malestar de las clases medias y altas
con el gasto en ayudas sociales que
había fomentado el partido de los
trabajadores políticas que muchos
consideraban un gasto inadmisible y una
forma de fomentar que los más pobres no
trabajaran
el mandatario brasileño también se
caracterizó por sus constantes polémicas
y su discurso polarizante durante sus
cuatro años se facilitó el acceso a
comprar armas aumentando su venta en un
300% se privilegió la agenda de grupos
ultraconservadores como los evangelistas
o se negó el efecto negativo de la
deforestación en el Amazonas algo que
aumentó su destrucción
es una falacia decir que la amazonía es
patrimonio de la humanidad
y un error confirmado por los
científicos decir que nuestros bosques
amazónicos son el pulmón del mundo
Aunque probablemente su mayor polémica
se dio durante la pandemia el mandatario
brasileño se convirtió en uno de los
líderes mundiales más escépticos con
respecto a la gravedad del coronavirus
una postura que hizo que rechazara los
confinamientos masivos y que le llevó a
cuestionar la efectividad de las vacunas
e incluso el origen del virus al acusar
a China de su creación además la crisis
sanitaria llevó a una profunda crisis
económica que lo obligó a dar marcha
atrás a sus intenciones de eliminar las
ayudas sociales de bolsa familia Y
aunque terminó con el programa insignia
del lulismo creó otro llamado auxilio
Brasil que sirvió para que se ganase el
apoyo de los receptores más empobrecidos
pero lo cierto Es que su futuro y
viabilidad está cuestio tras las
elecciones de 2022 es en este contexto
en el que llegan los dos candidatos a
una segunda vuelta especialmente
polarizada donde dos modelos de país y
sociedad se enfrentan con esto
concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France
24.com
[Música]